it does really feel like there's this
huge blind spot
i i understand that commercial interests
mean that certain organizations
will pay huge prices in order to
criticize china but it's it surprises me
in a world that's so decentralized where
you have individual creators that can
put things out on youtube or even
blockchain hosted video hosting websites
now you have people with huge huge
platforms that are talking about
everything anything and everything there
is a topic and a reddit thread and a
discord server and a
you know there's a twitter account for
it
it seems
so bizarre to me that there's this huge
human rights violation going on
that nobody's paying any attention to
and yet
animal rights global warming
are these huge movements have you got
any idea
why
culturally
it's not being picked up more by people
because
whatever this twisted people minds they
got right whatever thing i mean the
thing is people america especially
obsessed with slavery
i mean it happened sorry 18th century it
happened a long time ago
and there are literally people right now
being enslaved in this 21st century so
the thing is if the slavery that matters
that happened like a few centuries ago
why this library is happening right now
it's not matter to you and that's the
the biggest hypocrisy is that if the
song slavery matters why this kind of
slave that doesn't bother you at all
right this is why it's all about how
this became almost like identity
politics it's all about their narrative
all about winning their own power so
i think this we are seeing that i mean
we know that hitler
became voted to come into power he
didn't like
start a coup people voted for him to
become on the power
and venezuela too right even cuba as
well it wasn't
so even north korea keemer's son too
like people voted for him we wanted him
and there is no no guarantee it's not
going to happen in the west
it is possible i mean it happened not to
germany so
that i think when people lose that what
is right they lose a sense of
i think right now it's like everything i
mean the biggest problems these kids
that have i saw at columbia the their
pronouns if somebody don't know do not
call their right pronoun what exists
whatever this weird word x y z whatever
this thing is
this is the biggest oppression they ever
feel in their lifetime
and we are raising a generation or
brainwashing a generation think that is
the biggest problem in the world
and they're keeping them in the bubble
like they do not understand how rare it
is for the individuals to be free
and even know what individualism is like
in north korea there's no word for i
we don't even know the word i
so when i went to south korea they were
asking introduce yourself and this is
all north koreans do like we from north
korea
we from haitian we love like this food
and they're like what do you mean we
like you you i
and in north korea that's how they
like even get rid of this concept like
freedom human rights and i
and the fact that we know what i is
that's a privilege
and of course these people for them is
the biggest oppression is that you know
the pronouns so
yeah i don't know i'm are you hopeful
not really to be honest yeah i mean
it seems like
china is such an obvious
target
for everybody to be concerned about
the
militarization of the south china sea i
watched some documentary about this the
other day that's
terrifying
they are taking over territory in
northern pakistan they've got this belt
and road initiative
they are exporting more and more
technology around the world they've got
disinformation campaigns and then you
see how easy it is to socially or
culturally hijack countries like the uk
or the us with particular movements and
even now
the skepticism around is this actually
people from the uk or the us talking
about this problem online or is this
just state actors from russia or from
china that are talking about this when
you combine all of this and then
what i really would love to educate
myself more on is
the long-term plans of china i know
obviously there's no booklets somewhere
where they've just said oh this is what
we fancy doing but obviously
the rumors and the obvious impact
implication is that they would want to
expand the ccp across the entire world
and
like that's an existential threat that's
a threat to the entire globe
yeah
and
because companies want to make money
and because governments don't want to
lose out on import and export duty or
don't want to make waves nobody's
talking about it like if you leave a
problem longer and longer
it just gets harder and harder to fix
and
i mean
what more obvious of a potential
issue could you have than a global
pandemic released from
perhaps a wuhan lab
like
it's just an endless there's an endless
laundry list an endless laundry list of
things that have happened that should
have caused some repercussions
for china
there's zero reproduction right i mean
they are blaming people saying it's
coming from china and they call us
racist
that's what they're spending their
energy on right it's like um
i mean
it's coming from china we know that
and china even if it's not coming from
the lab let's say that let me move that
it was happening in china they had to
report to the world organization be
transparent about it
right we could have ended there if we
knew all what it was
they had all the genetic code of coffee
and they could they that was their duty
to report
health organization warning everybody
what was happening they didn't do that
they would keep saying no it's nothing
it's nothing no transmission no nothing
so even that was enough for them to be
hold accountable for what they have done
to entire humanity they cared more than
2 million people around the globe
imagine americans do that can you
imagine like if the uk did that
the world is going to attack us all if
chinese does it of course like all
everybody's defending them right now
even though people in america is
defending them and i'm not sure if
anyone's defending them i think that
people are willfully being ignorant to
them i think that people aren't pointing
the finger in the way that they should
um
but yeah
i wonder whether the
deconstruction of patriotism and of
pride in countries like the uk and the
usa
it wouldn't so i mean if it's not
russia or china's plan they must be
sitting back and thinking they're just
doing our work for us because the one
thing that would work against an
aggressive nation state like russia or
china would be a proud country that said
we
want to protect our national sovereignty
we're concerned about what's happening
over there and you create an in-group
and out-group dynamic right you have the
out-group that's china we need to
protect ourselves perhaps we're stewards
of the earth you know usa used to be the
people team usa i know it's a satirical
movie but that the whole movie was all
about them being guardians of the globe
and um
because national pride's been
disintegrated a lot especially over the
last
two years
no one
really wants to stand up for that
anymore it's very uncool you've got this
fragmented idea about what it means to
be an american or a patriot people are
embarrassed about their country's
history do you think this
this is the perfect breeding ground
for an aggressive party to come and take
over because no one's going to fight
back
but that's the thing i think it's not
just that this happened this way at this
point i think some kind of behind the
scene
thing have infiltrated this way
i don't think american people chose to
be this way and be so
ungrateful and so ignorant of the past
and the history right like
i mean slavery began the dawn of
humanity it's still happening
and still holding the slavery pissing
against the entire american nation and
saying this country only solution to
this country is tear down everything
and rebuild something right that's the
thing these people in the u.s now
voluntarily want to bring down the
country bring down the system
and bring i mean like get rid of the
constitution right
so
but i don't know that's just began on
their own or somebody who were
influenced it feels like they've been
hijacked somehow doesn't it yeah it just
feels like it's not a conspiracy theory
at this point how the country
making that much progress
right like from there to here we have
made so much progress as a humanity
coming here but suddenly
going against exactly system allowing
this progress to happen
and do not want to kind of going back
and what what is this everything is
reversing the regression is happening
right now voluntarily
and i don't know what happened how it's
possible well isn't it crazy that you
have north korea a country with very low
living standards where the population is
forced to love the country and america a
country with very high living standards
where the population is now hating the
country yes
it's so bad
this is the only country i saw that
people hate the country but i want to be
here
how many people i want
how many people trying to come to this
country if this is really that bigotry
and systemically racist country the
worst country you think is why
everybody's trying to come and why would
you not even live go away just go to
north korea if you want that much just
go to china right nobody trying to
immigrate to north korea and china
and that's the thing that proves this is
a
good great country and now i think that
becomes a very controversial way
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace